I wish there was just more compassion no
we don't want to make something
difficult we just want to be
acknowledged my daughter was a victim
and she's being punished hey guys
welcome to another episode of the
Wednesday checkup sorry we're in the
crazy furry rug space here today at
YouTube but I wanted to get this video
out as soon as possible
when I heard that there was a video made
between anti-vaccine pro-vaccine folks I
decided to watch it and give you my
reaction live right here first time
watching it I'm Bob Sears I'm a
pediatrician a pediatrician who is anti
vaccine interesting his passion is just
to help encourage full complete and
foreign consent for vaccinations doesn't
sound like he's anti vaccine he said
he's in favor of informed consent I
think all doctors at least they should
be for informed consent curious where
this is going well I was vaccinated as a
child but my last vaccine was about 15
years ago when I returned to college and
I had a severe reaction and that I
became arthritic in my hands went to
many many doctors and nobody knew what
was going on and why it was happening
and then just shot like it doesn't make
sense you're too young to have arthritis
and it wasn't until having kids and sort
of digging into my own research for them
that a lot of answers started coming up
and I think it's unfortunate that a lot
of it is overlooked I guess maybe I'll
participate in this this could be a cool
way to do it I am vaccinated if I were
to have children they'd be vaccinated
and I am a doctor who's pro vaccine
becoming an anti vaccine activist based
on your own experience of having a
negative outcome to a vaccine to me is
not wise and I'll point out why I
believe that if you look at the
statistical evidence between the harms
that can come from vaccines because
there are some harms and then you look
at what you're preventing essentially
what are the benefits what diseases are
you preventing by getting a vaccine
there's so much benefit they're horrible
that the mother and activists had this
thing happened to her but it shouldn't
be the sole reason for why someone
believes that vaccines are bad and
they're anti-vaccine I will acknowledge
of course as a pediatrician I know
vaccines work I know they give you
protection today they vary greatly and
what that protection is it's not like
100% magical shield over you completely
I don't understand where this doctor
falls under anti vaccine if that's his
stance I think when you're giving kids
medication you have to get micro about
it I don't think it's doing your kids
any service to just save X scenes are
all made the same and they're all safe
and healthy good for you that
everybody's benefiting from it because
she's right
Falls well we studied them before we
released them to the public we study
them so we do know they're safe that's
the thing is we ish safer you know being
an intensive acai see the worst of the
worst and so seeing the other side of
kids who don't get vaccinated I saw a
kid walking in with meningococcemia
which I haven't seen in decades he had
all four limbs cut off they had to be
amputated because it was all dead tissue
and forget how bad things were before we
had vaccines I'm really proud that the
intensivists took this route because
many times subspecialists will often run
to talking about statistics or studies
and research and to people who are not
of scientific education it's difficult
to relate to that but when you tell a
powerful story like he just did that
really strikes the message home that
children are dying they're losing limbs
unnecessarily I agree with the mother on
the vaccine issue
this shouldn't be a macro issue this is
a micro issue each vaccine should be
evaluated but the truth of the matter is
is they are we don't just say all
vaccines are good we look at each
individual vaccine each individual
vaccine has a different set of adverse
reactions aka bad things that can happen
as a result of getting them but again
the trade-off in taking the risk of
having one of these adverse reactions is
the protection from the disease that we
hope to prevent or even eradicate at
times I don't like the assumption that
if a child is unvaccinated somehow they
are of risk to everyone and also knowing
that vaccinated individuals can also be
caring and spreading diseases I think
it's very polarizing to separate the two
as if if you're vaccinated you're
totally fine you're not risking
anybody anything I disagree with her
because if you're vaccinated it doesn't
mean you're not risking anyone it means
when you're vaccinated you're doing your
job to protect those who cannot be
vaccinated it doesn't mean that you're a
great person it doesn't speak to your
lack of ability to do harm but that's
not what the point of the issue is the
point of the issue is if you choose not
to vaccinate your children and you're
okay with your child getting measles or
one of these illnesses what about the
children that have an immunodeficiency
or have some sort of other issue that
they can't get vaccines and as a result
of that your child then spreads a deadly
illness to them and they die too anybody
could be spreading diseases especially
things like polio and pertussis that are
not completely covered by the vaccine
again I agree that not everybody's
covered but if you can reduce that
likelihood why wouldn't you I started
out vaccinating my daughter because I
believed all the same things that you
said it wasn't until she had a reaction
and several reactions that I actually
had to look at it differently where I I
realized by continuing vaccinating for
her that actually would hurt her and yet
everyone wants me to do it for the
population this is a very specific
situation this is where things get
tricky
if you're having adverse reactions to
vaccines I don't think there's any
doctor in the world who says continue
getting vaccines to protect all of us it
doesn't matter if the vaccines hurt your
daughter in fact one of the first
questions I ask before I administer
vaccines is have you ever had adverse
events what were they and we investigate
them prior to giving vaccines if your
child for some reason cannot get a
vaccine because of adverse events you
fall into the population that needs to
be protected by herd immunity a number
of families who look into vaccines they
will decide to opt out of vaccines
because they feel they are just not
willing to risk the side-effects for the
side effects or the side effects are
like one in a million one or two million
whereas the side effects from the
diseases when I see all these outbreaks
and things like I'm gonna choose
vaccines every time and that's I think
right there is the disservice to this
conversation because it is a risk
benefit analysis and what's unfortunate
is how downplayed those risks are I only
started investigating vaccines because I
ended up with a kid with an autoimmune
disorder autoimmune disorders have been
present before vaccinations work
what's interesting here is yes it may
not be one in a million or one and two
million whatever the odds are the bottom
line of why it shouldn't be an optional
thing of opting out from vaccines when
at least when it comes to public schools
is because a herd immunity exists be
it's my job as the doctor to make sure
the parent is giving quality care to the
child if the child had a broken bone and
the parent wasn't adequately treating it
and didn't want to go see a doctor and
the child was suffering as a result I
can report them to the proper
authorities it doesn't mean that because
they're your child you can just do
whatever so by not getting vaccinations
it's medically and statistically proven
that you're endangering your child to
develop these deadly diseases
therefore we don't allow you to opt out
at least we don't allow you to opt out
from schools and that's sort of our
catch-all behind this the one in a
million is not a real number and so
you're more that that is put out is it
so people think that no it's not not
when you're talking about the different
kind of reactions I think the number
you're referring to is anaphylactic
shock that anaphylactic shock is of
course extremely rare
whereas you when you look at seizures
from the MMR vaccine are one in 3,000
but again is creative ear when we worry
what we worry that you get those on your
side kind of downplay those we don't
necessarily downplay them we weigh them
against the benefits of getting the
vaccine and if you're getting a vaccine
is preventing you from getting an
illness which vaccines have been proven
over time to do this the one in 3,000
statistic is difficult to conceptualize
for a parent because they don't know how
often the actual disease occurs as a
result of this we as doctors make the
recommendation that taking the one in
3,000 risk of having a seizure is worth
it to prevent this deadly illness from
happening I don't think it's an idea of
downplay I think it comes back to what
we were saying with the risk benefit
analysis and I think the data is very
clear it's so hard not to talk about
data when you're talking about vaccines
as a doctor but unfortunately when
you're trying to influence someone and
you're trying to change their mind on
something doesn't work well and I
imagine this is gonna fall on deaf ears
to trust someone who sees your child for
10 minutes twice a year in the end
parents know their children best I
actually very much disagree with that
statement the closer you are in relation
to the patient the more likely that your
bias is going to be at play you're not
going to be able to make an objective
decision this is why it's strongly
discouraged in the medical community to
take care of your own family members as
a doctor because your judgment gets
clouded and you make bad decisions so if
you were to come to your doctor and say
hey my child's acting differently after
this this well visit appointment
something's wrong you want them to trust
that you have an established
relationship and listen to you she's
absolutely right if a parent brings in a
child and says they're acting
differently that's a huge warning sign
and any doctor that brushes that off and
says aha I disagree that's a bad sign
from a doctor I would actually recommend
switching doctors or in the room if
you're comfortable pointing that out to
the doctor that you don't think that's
the right method and you're not
comfortable if they don't welcome your
criticism or your thoughts on the matter
switch doctors it's really that simple
my daughter has epilepsy and in March
she was also diagnosed with juvenile
idiopathic arthritis I went to the
rheumatologist and the rheumatologist
said we're gonna put her on methotrexate
and I looked at her I'm like
methotrexate that's a chemotherapy the
Kimber therapeutic agent that you know
kids with cancer get and she's like yes
but we use it in a low dose and it
doesn't cause harmful side effects you
have to trust me I said okay and I
trusted her and I am so glad that I did
before all this happened she was a
competitive gymnast and she used to walk
up and down the stairs like she was 90
years old she couldn't hold a pencil in
her hand now she's back on the bars and
back on the on the beam
doing things which my wife and I never
thought that she would do again I'm so
proud of these doctors that they're
coming in and really avoiding digging
into data and numbers and confusing and
confounding the conversation further
they're telling personal stories they're
making it emotional they're making it
reasonable because this is how
you resonate with another human being
it's not about pointing at a pie chart
the people who refuse to acknowledge
that vaccine reactions are happening or
that the things that happened to my
daughter were connected because maybe it
was just a coincidence and I just needed
something to pin it on you are socially
isolated you can be isolated by your
family isolated by the medical community
community isolated by society as a whole
because they assume you're unintelligent
uneducated and irrational I don't think
we should become hostile to anti-vaxxers
I think the the role here is to be
compassionate and when a patient tells
me something that I know to be
misinformation I don't get mad at the
patient the feelings that I get are oh
man I'm it's so unfortunate that you've
come to believe that and this is what I
say to myself in my head how can I find
a common ground between us so that I can
explain to you what's actually happening
or what the right steps are to fix this
situation I think where hostility really
kicks in is now when a single person
refuses to vaccinate their children but
when they become activists to try and
encourage other people to not vaccinate
their children that sort of
misinformation spreading is really
dangerous and that's where it deserves
to be struck down right away because if
you're not going to be talking about
quality evidence you're gonna be talking
about expert opinion you're just doing a
huge disservice to a lot of families I
have a great deal of compassion for the
families that had children die from
preventable diseases there shouldn't be
any hostility there should be discussion
I mean we can always question things and
that's how we of all that's how we get
better if we didn't question anything
we'd be still in the dark ages a huge
fan of that doctor I'm glad they did
this but I am also gonna be a little bit
of a skeptic here the people that were
invited from the anti-vaccine side were
very reasonable they were very logical
they talked about their own experiences
if they invited the people that are
shouting in front of doctors offices if
they invited the true activists that
think doctors are killing people if they
invite some of the people that email me
telling me that I'm killing babies and
that I need to watch certain pieces of
propaganda that they're spreading around
Val
have been a totally different
conversation it would have been hostile
it would have been explosive the only
way that we can control the situation is
by educating those people that are in
the middle ground now by telling them
what to do but by educating them by
explaining how look how horrible it was
before we had vaccines
talk to the w-h-o and let them tell you
how many lives are lost every minute
when children don't have money to get a
vaccine we are blessed to live in a time
and in a country where vaccines are made
affordable to us made available to us in
fact we have a program in my hospital
called vaccine for children that if you
don't even have insurance coverage we
still get vaccines for these children
these are government-aided programs that
are not-for-profit they're for
protection of children that's what
vaccines are all about they're about
protecting children they're about making
sure that we get the best outcomes
possible and we continue to monitor this
if new research occurs that vaccines
have a new side effect that we weren't
aware of we take this into account and
we update our recommendations but as of
right now the benefits outweigh the
harms when it comes to vaccines and you
should vaccinate your children just as I
will mine in the future and I recommend
the same to all my patients if you're
still curious to learn more about
vaccines click here for my vaccine video
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]